So Perry and I have been running
the executive programs at the D School
at Stanford for the last several year.
And we've had the great pleasure
of hosting hundreds and
thousands of professionals,
just like you, at Stanford, getting them
immersed in the tools of design thinking.
But we weren't satisfied just
with hosting professionals here.
Our goal with Innovation at Work is to
take the same tools that we teach here at
Stanford and
bring them in to your context.
In to your office and put them to work
on challenges that matter to you.
>> So
how it is going to work is each portion
of Innovation at Work has two sections.
One is about actually practicing a skill
and the other is doing it at work.
The way it's gonna work is we will
give an instructional video, and
there are injections even throughout that
that'll run concurrent with your work.
So you'll be working
sometimes right beside us.
Sometimes we'll prompt you to do work,
and you'll dive right into it.
Whatever it is, though, I assure you
it's gonna be active in the room.
You're gonna be up,
you're gonna be moving, and
you're gonna be using
these tools real time.
>> This Innovation at Work
course is different from
any other online course you've taken.
For two reasons.
One, it's actually project based, meaning,
that we'll give some instruction and
then you're working on a real project.
The second thing is, rather than sitting
with your own computer at your desk,
doing the class by yourself,
you'll be with a group of your colleagues,
working on developing these tools and
applying them to your challenge together.
So people who generally come to Innovation
at Work, leave their laptops at their
desk, and come with an attitude ready to
engage and collaborate and an openness
to try on new tools of innovation to
bring back to their team and their work.
>> So these Innovation at Work sessions
will each be about 90 minutes.
The first one will always be practice,
we'll actually go through a skill and
actually sort of tool you up and
actually use a challenge that we have to
teach you the tools that
we want you to learn.
The second one will always be about
a problem that you have in your work and
we'll apply those tools to that challenge.
In the sessions, we'll give instruction
and videos sometimes demonstrating.
We'll give a certain amount
of time to get it done but
know that if you need to hit play or
pause during the session.
>> That's pretty cool.
[LAUGH] You can do that and you can
actually continue on with the session
as if we were there the whole time.
>> Right.
>> The goal though is for
you to take these tools seriously and
for you to feel confident and
capable of applying them to
work that matters to you.
>> Yeah and one more thing I forgot
to tell you, the sessions are active.
>> You won't need a computer at all.
>> That's great.
[SOUND]